welcome to IBM cloud as an IT operations
administrator you had your choice of any
number of cloud providers you chose IBM
cloud because it's a leader in cloud as
a service we offer superior levels of
security functionality integration
interoperability and usability use the
IBM cloud console to get access to our
catalog of over 190 unique services
across several categories including
security compute network storage
integration and data management in
addition to the catalog there are a
variety of tools to help you plan your
hosting environment before you begin
provisioning it one tool is the IBM
cloud design decision tool which helps
you compare infrastructure designs so
you can build the best IBM cloud
solution to suit your needs
after you've planned and designed your
infrastructure use the Cost Estimator to
see how much your infrastructure will
cost before placing your order you can
access it by clicking the icon in the
console menu bar the IT operations
administrator journey walks you through
the various stages of planning building
and managing your environment the
journey contains links to the compute
storage and networking options offered
by IBM cloud and information on the IBM
cloud platform as a service and software
as a service IBM cloud offers you a
strong support network that includes
forums and wiki's as well as Support
Specialists to answer your questions as
a member of IBM cloud IT operations
administrator family you have the
support of designers developers and
other IT operations administrators who
share the same ideas and risks as you do
know that you have the support of IBM
cloud to once again welcome